حيث تظهر على الركائز في
بحاجة لالتقاط مهنة العاصفة
تعبت منك الطبيب yefima سيتم اطلاق الماشية و
في انتظاره نظرا الوظيفي الكتان تامينو
البذور والولادة لنائب الشعب ديمين حينها
كرة القدم في قناع الرسوم
أعلى من ذلك 100 n صلاة لك هذا ألفا
وتقلى ريشة
علينا الفوز بزاوية متغير المداعبات
المنصوص عليها
ذهب
كل مخرج يشبه السير على لغم
حقل
لدينا الرافيولي شورز مثل رئيس العاهرة
موسكو الذي يعجبه الكابل بهذا و shure
فيلم طول جوليا الروح فيها على فيدون
لذلك فإن الأسماك تتوقف عن التركيز عليها
لا أعرف تجربتي والناس حتى الآن
chuyka هناك هذا ضروري هنا هذا ليس كذلك
فلدي عضلة على كين أتلي تا تا تا أوه حاخام
وقد مزقت الأرواح ساحرة الخلية وفركنا نحن العام
م a اسم ثانوس سينقذ العالم
لدينا أعياد مدنية على العكس من ذلك
إنه عمل
ومن هو أزرق
أسطول أربو ويقلى هذه اللعبة ألما الملكية
Khadyr يزيل فيروس الإنترنت وسوف أقوم بالتحديث
إما meliorn
واحد هو مكتب الروبل المألوف لرفض
محللو الأحمق بروم الحرارة قبالة إم akhadir
رياضي له حجم مكعب فيلماكس هائل
لدينا حوالي ألفي متجر
منصات الإنترنت التي تغطي
بما في ذلك موسكو ، أعتقد أن المبدأ هو ذلك
جريمة منظمة
جاء مخدرات نفس الإرهاب
يغذيها بيع الأسلحة و
هذا هو كل المال يأتي من هنا
وبعدهم نقود لنا نعطيها فرهاد بالفعل
فمه لي عالم من الفوضى
وقت الرعد جمع باقات ثم هناك
انتم مهاجرون
أثارت الأوباش حرارة بريتون كبيرة بصوت عال
واسعة تيمبي أميليا التقاطات منه
التوازن هينا فاليرا بيديت إيدو المشي مع
يوليو في مزارع المشغلين
اتجاه صعب جدا صعب جدا
هنا شخصية ساعدنا من أجلها
نعمل كل رب المخدرات منتصف الليل نحن
دعونا نربح قناع الفيديو نحن أقوياء للغاية
قسم أداء المهمة
الدعم المادي لجميع الأنشطة
إدارة أو سيطرة لدينا
المهمة هي تدمير
حاول العمل لكتابة واحدة فقط
فرصة للاستفادة من الطلقات النارية
وحدة النخبة ترشح إضافي
اليوم الذي يتطلب كبير جدا
على سبيل المثال لا في العطاء الذاتي في وقت ما
تعمل الممارسات أمامنا
ندخل
خضعوا للكثير من الاختبارات
نفسية وهي جسدية
يحدث فقط هؤلاء سيد الرياضة ولكن
الذي لم يخدم في الجيش لا يفهم
أن الكتبة ، مع ذلك ، شخص جيد و
كبار السن في نوبات يخشى بعض المحاربين
الرجل الذي يأتي ليخدم الرعد
يتم تجنيده ، وليس من يختاره الرؤساء
يجب أن يشاهد فريق الفريق
كيف يتصرف في أي موقف و
يمارس مهاراته البدنية و
أخلاقيا أي كيف سينتهي به الأمر
مجموعة اختبار التحمل تشغيل ثلاثة
كيلومترات واذا لم يجتاز هذا
المرحلة ثم الاختيار لم يعد مستمرًا
انتقل إلى تدريب القوة بعد ذلك
بعد أن أكملنا كل مادي
تعطى التمارين دقيقتين لكل منهما
معدات
كل الجولات لمدة دقيقة واحدة مع كل منها
موظف يقف في دائرة
كل رجل يخرج طازجا
جميعهم يسقطون ولكنهم جميعًا يرتفعون
القوة الجسدية تنتهي بعد
تشغيله فقط يذهب نظيف
شخصية أي قوة الإرادة
بالطبع نحن لا نجرب الرجل هناك
تدمير اقتل وهلم جرا ولكن المهام
في مكان ما لكل قوتك
فزت بجولتين أو ثلاث وقفت
بعد 3 كانت صعبة بالفعل بعد كل
ارتفع هبوط وأنا الآن أواجه
لا تتخلى عن مواصلة القتال حتى النهاية
تقول الكثير ، إنها لدينا
المرشح أعطي محمد أو أنا عبارات الأرض
مطارق البحرية مهمتها التدرب بهذه الطريقة
مقاتلينا
بحيث يكون كل من يبحث عن رفيق وفيا له
الرفيق مائة بالمائة على ما يبدو
ساعي المخدرات تصل إلى بعض تصمد
كان الرجل الصغير هناك منذ 20 عامًا ، لكن نعم ، هو كل شيء هناك
60 كيلوغراما من الناس في غاية الخطورة
تأتي عبر نفس العمل نعم وهناك
أموال طائلة حيث يوجد أموال طائلة
خطر كبير
هذه المهمة تستحق كل هذا العناء حتى يكون التأثير
مفاجآت
لم يكن لدى الجاني الوقت للرد.
ما ولا حتى نوع من الأسلحة
للوصول حتى لا يكون لديه وقت للعودة
هناك شقق بوسين أمام المحكمة ، نحن أيضًا ، بعد كل شيء
الرجل الحديدي لن يفتحها بنفسه إذا كنت
لي توني ستارك يعني ticically وهكذا
ثم يحاول تدمير
في الوقت الحالي لدينا
المقاتلين على ارتفاعات عالية من الكتب في نفس الوقت
العمل والمنظر من الجانب والأبواب من
بلدانهم لمنع
تدمير هذه الخطوة يعني الرجل
لا يجب أن يكون جسديا فقط
اختراق الجدار هناك وهلم جرا
يجب أن يفكر ويخطط
يفكرون أيضًا في العملية وهو لا يريدها
أن تكون
حالات المستضعف وفي هذا
يجب أن نكون الفائزين
لا نحتاج إلى خيار للجميع
للتدرب كل يوم يمكنك أن تتعلم و
أطلق النار جيدًا ولكن إذا حدث ذلك لاحقًا
التدريب قبل ذلك يشبه السلاح
لا يصلح على الإطلاق سوف تذكره
لكن الأيدي لن تفعل
يبدأ الهجوم على المبنى الذي ندخله
إطلاق النار ولا ينبغي أن يضيع شخص في
لديها خوارزمية معينة
يجب أن يؤدي الرجل
دائما تدفع لعملك لا
بغض النظر عما حتى عندما ننفق
نوع من التدريس ، على التوالي ، شخص
في التدريبات يجب أن يعدوا أنفسهم أيضًا
وبالضبط في نفس الحالة
للقيادة من أجل أن يكون العمل
يجب أن يكون الشخص الكفء دائمًا في وضع التشغيل
على الشاطئ وفي ملهى ليلي للفندق مع الجعة
من الجري بصوت عال كانت طعام العمري وهكذا و
الحرارة من لعبة الصواريخ أو
صدت وتهميش أنا أنت موسكو
النشاط الصيدلاني
يعني قانوني
دوران
ولكن مرة أخرى كان الجانب المظلل للغاية
تطوير النظام الجاد
كريستي 8-9 الضباب باع تلك المواد
التي تم إطلاقها
جزء من هذا الكائن الخاص بالمجال
ضع عملك في مسار معين
الأحداث ، تم الاستيلاء على أكثر من 18 ألف
أقراص وأكثر من ألفي دواء
كانت سريعة وفعالة
في نفس الوقت يعطي موظفي العمليات
الأمر وكلها في نفس الوقت أدخل السبب
يتم ذلك من أجل
المعلومات التي لا ترسل إليها
لم يكن لدى المجسم أو الأوغاد الوقت
تدمير الأدلة
أعتقد أننا أنقذنا هذا العمل
ربما الكثير من الأرواح
في العجلات من وغيّر الإصدار مرة واحدة ثم
أخذت فيليا أبطال العرض
كنت أسير من النار إلى السير والأحذية
تسمية المتنمرون أنا كل الكلاب تعمل
يبدأ بقدومك و
ضع طوق عليها ومن ذلك
في اللحظة التي يعرف فيها الكلب بالفعل ما الذي يركب عليه
من الآن يبدأ
تقلق مثلك تمامًا
يخدم لاهوتيًا تمامًا
واجب ثقيل كل يوم كل يوم
شيء ما يجري في السرقات
السرقات والسطو الجسدي الخطير
الاغتصاب الضرر جزء لكل تريليون
أكد درجته مهمة تعني
عندما تأكل الكلب يجب عليك الاتصال
يكون إذا كان الاتصال سيئا بشكل طبيعي
عمل الكلب تورا
ليست جيدة جدا ولكن ماذا
كل شيء على ما يرام
لا يزال متناسقًا مع كل رحيل عندما تذهب
تقترب أكثر فأكثر
من هي الحقائب هناك
رئيس حتى تجد هنا
تنظر إلى الكلب وأحيانًا الكلب
هل يمكن أن تشعر به عليك هذا
أنت رابط لا ينفصل
لا مشكلة كبيرة ، قلتها في كل مرة
كيف تمشي من خلال حقيقة حقل الألغام بيري
حمل ألبا قدميها
أعيش لهم المصاعد الجديدة borats على المتوقع
نوع آخر من السيارات
يجب أن يتبع الكلب lidalili الطريق
جعل الشيء الاختيار جعل الاختيار
رجل القبض على مجرم
الكلب يتبع المسار الذي تتبعه لك
الموصل الذي تنظر إليه وأي و
يمكن التنقل هناك عبر البلدان في مكان ما
تكون الأشياء التي أسقطت المجرم
أثناء الركض المغادرة استدرت
لا أحد يرافقك متخلفًا بالفعل
lynch أنك شريكك أنت و
هل صدقته
أنت لا تعلم أنه يعاني من نوبة صرع
لكن مسدسك قد توقف ، فأنت خائف من السلايم
كلب
أنت لست خائفًا على الإطلاق وبشكل عام تذهب إلى الشرطة
في الواقع ، لم يؤد الركاب ثمارهم
لرحلة عملت سأتبعها
2014 سرقات كثيرة
سرق سائقي سيارات الأجرة ضرب السارق
في الوجه
لديها سائق تاكسي في هذه اللحظة نحن نطير
متجر أسلحة وهرب
تركت آثارًا حاولت الشرطة العثور عليها
لم نحصل على أي شيء بأنفسنا
وصل عمل الماء عند المدخل
وضع الكلب
تميز الشقة لما الموظفين
فضيحة لا ولكن لا يمكن أن يكون هم و
تظهر الصعود إلى الطابق الثاني من الجذع
هنا الدم
ولكن مرة أخرى ظهرت القاعدة الأولى
كلاب
لقد ارتبكت في البداية ثم
تولى يدك تطبيق مرة أخرى لا
لم يصعد إلي مرة أخرى
استلقي في هذه الشقة سأقوم بالحجز 10
هنا
رفعت الحصيرة ارتفعت في مثل هذه الثقوب
العقيد وهم تحت هذه الثقوب
انتشرت الصورة وبدأت في الاحتكاك والآن
لك على المقياس
أنت والكلاب لا تفهمون نعم هو كذلك
حركتي
لن ينجح شيء ما وهناك بنفسك
ثلاث وثلاثون مرة ش لتقرر
لا أعرف ، مثل هذا ، سوف تمزق من الداخل ، لكن
لا يمكنك لمس كلب إذا سحقته
منازل
الانتظار بالفعل سيذهب إلى نفسه ليس ولكن لا
الجرافة تقاتل هناك ، أحسنت مع الرجل الذكي
الكلب يجب أن نعيشه حقًا
ليس قاذفة الرمل لعناصر ASOS التي ننتظر الإصدار عليها
المليار هو ما تعتقده وتفكر في الهجوم عليه
طرق عربة الجحيم تقسيم الأسماك وتفل x أنت
سعيد أنه يحتاج إلى العثور على لا بد منه من
مصدر الرائحة لا أفعل
أعلم أن الكل سوف يطير هكذا
متفجرات على مستوى مختلف تماما
الكلاب انه هادئ جدا قياس لها
حتى شمها بهدوء لا قدر الله من ورائها
ليؤذي أنني لم أؤذي التمدد وكل هذا و
ليس لديك كلب ولا يوجد أشخاص
للأيام التي تذهب فيها الكائنات الحية بنفس الطريقة
كأننا مع كل شخص
حتى معصوم من الخطأ والكلاب كل
بمجرد أن أتدرب أتدرب
هنا يبدو كل شيء كما لو كان ضروريًا في الألعاب
الحياة هنا قلت للمستقبل الغبي
عندما يدق القلب
في انسجام نعم يا صديقي سوف تجد التغيير
الفتيات
[موسيقى]
فتاة جيدة
عرض جيد
[موسيقى]
هنا جهاز محاكاة للعبوة الناسفة
هنا قضيت جزءًا من الثانية في الإحماء ، وهذا
الحياة إلى الحرية ليست لي فقط
لكنك أيضًا وحدة نمطية أو محلل و
اللعنة عليك جورب
تخلصت من فرك البيرة بالطبع silyavki لك
أنا مثل نامي الفارسي نامي هذا هو
كتب حمصه واجباتي هذا
خدمة حراسة الدورية
النظام العام والأمن
لص لا يعمل وحده
بشكل فردي ، نحن لا نقدم مثل هذا
القوة جميعًا معًا
لهذا السبب نقوم بعمل مكواة تجعيد الخطوة الرابعة
العيون شائعة
ليس لنا هناك اتضح أكثر قليلاً
هذه العيون الأربع
مزيد من suntour إلى شريط جعل المصطلح حظا سعيدا
ضحية حاخام
abelhawk الحسناء وفير العالم سيقاتل
للضغط على 10 لتغيير الملابس أحضر حصانًا
نظف
ما لا يقل عن ساعة ونصف إلى
الاستعداد لتجميع الرؤوس بالكامل
ذيل الكتب حتى تتمكن من المجيء
عدد حلقات اليد تيار الغذاء الدراجة اللباس
21 عاما تستحق إذا جاز التعبير
المتقاعدين أعطيت الرفوف إذا لم يكن كذلك
رائع يمكنك فعل كل شيء
أدرك أنني بالفعل حصلت عليه تماما
مجرد الشيخوخة
كسر حصان نمت بالفعل لماذا أنت و
إجبار عديم الفائدة كل ذلك من خلال
التفاهم والمثابرة
أظهر الوقت وأظهر الأخ وأظهر
في المرة الرابعة أدرك بالفعل أنه
إذا فعل ما أريد
يحصل عليها الناس لاكوست في كثير من الأحيان
رد عليك قل لي
الخير وهذا جيد
أنك ممثل القانون ، ما زلت
الفتاة يجعلهم كذلك
صدى لديك القانون حيث له
تنصحهم
كذلك الأمر متروك لك كيف لك
أتصرف على هذا النحو ، سوف أتصرف على هذا النحو
منذ ذلك الحين وأنا أكتب لوكينا وهم من هنا و
السؤال الذي طرحه علينا المواطنون
زاوي مكلف الرجل الغرق رأيت
ذهبت هذه الحديقة وظهرت الكعب ، لقد فهمت بالفعل
حقيقة أنه ليس ضروريًا فقط في حقيبة الظهر
كان حفظ بالفعل حيث الوعي بالمياه على
سحب أي حريق
ثم سلم العمل الجريء كم
صعب وليس غير أخلاقي في كثير من الأحيان
كنت مستلقيا لتحترق بشدة في غضون أسبوع
حتى يقول بشكل خاص عطلة رأس السنة الجديدة
بالنسبة للمدنيين ، هذه أعياد لنا
على العكس من ذلك ، إنه مثل الحصان الذي يغش نفس الحصان
في خدمة خيلين مختلفين إذا
يركز على شيء واحد
الانتباه عندما تخدم في المدينة
إنها فكرة حشد كبير مستمر
هذه سرقة أدبية ، لكن بعض الحزم شيء ما
صاخبة إلى الأبد نحن أعلى من ذلك بكثير
الحشود نرى بعضنا البعض ما يحدث في أكثر
يمكننا مجموعة من ستة متسابقين
اسأل عما تمثله كيف يمكنك ذلك
حشد جدا ستة أشخاص فقط لا شيء
لم أفعل ذلك وسأل حقًا عن جزء كيف
يخاف الناس من الخيول والقليل
تصرف
لا يمكنك أن تخطئ في التدريب لذلك نحن
كان يومك مثاليا
هناك شخص يخاف من النار شخص ما
يخافون من مجرد التلويح بأيديهم
شخص أعلام نحن نعمل من أجل كرة القدم
أعلام الأحداث الجماعية ليست معنا
نادرًا ما يكون الحصان خائفًا فهو ليس كذلك
تكون قادرة على الخدمة
الخوف من النار يعني مثلي
تعال الآن سآخذك فقط
تهدئة مثل هذا حول نار المخيم
أحسنت صنعًا بمجرد أن ألاحظ أن الحصان
اهدأ ، يمكنك الاقتراب
أعطى استجابة هادئة إلى حد ما ل
يمكن الآن الاقتراب من النار
حتى أقرب إلى تشغيل حصان صغير
هذا الشيء خطير حتى في حالة الفشل
يقع ، تحتاج إلى إظهار ما يجب القيام به
لا أستطيع الآن أن أكون محترفًا مرة أخرى حتى
ينجح
تم مارس الجنس في سن المراهقة الفورمالين
الديكتاتوريات
واستنتاجات التمثال عنهم شيء Julie vs.
أو thimann حقًا لا يعجبه الناس
بالمرور لا يربت عليهم يبدؤون
على الفور ، وعدم الضغط على السطح الأملس
لفت انتباه القائد إليها
جاهز لك
أنا جاهز لأداء البهلوانية وأداءها
العناصر على ملاعق سباق الخيل
لم أكن بحاجة إلى واحدة كبيرة
الأكاذيب المرهقة لا يجب أن تكون صغيرة
صديقي اللطيف هو ليلة سعيدة للغاية
أطفاله هو مؤنس جدا و لكن
في الليل هي مكيدة هي الأصغر
لدينا حصان
بشكل عام ، مع موجة حنون ، يعطي أكثر
ش الصغيرة
إنهم يحبونها كثيرًا عندما نخدشها ستنسحب
جوجل سيكون لطيفا جدا
أنا أحب الخيول التي تنجذب إليها
الرجل ليس حتى أقف فقط
لا بد لي من ضرب لي على أي حال ، ولكن
هذا هو السبب في أنهم يمتطون ربما معه كذلك
تلاشت علاقتنا معك
raid0 مواقع أو ابننا الذي يعمل فيه
مجموعة إصلاح يذهبون حول الشباب
خرجت التي نأتي بها لأنفسنا
نقطة الصفر يقودونهم إلى التدريب بالفعل
بدأ البناء معًا يمشي
والتدريب على بعض هذه التربة
هناك الكثير من الأماكن للتواصل ، حسنًا ، شيء من هذا القبيل
كل شيء نما تدريجيا أكثر
ثقالة
[موسيقى]
لا أعرف ، لا أريد أن أتدرب
فقط اجلس في مكان ما
بالنسبة لنا فقط لالتقاط الصور
يجلس الحصان إنه ممل نحن فيه
فستان الزفاف في الدعاوى المصنوعة
عناصر كيس الأفراد
ملعقة حقيقية
لكن هذا يحدث والآن غالبًا ما أطلق حلبة
تشغيل أخرى بدوني وشمعة وبدون
قد يكذب الجميع فقط
شعرت بنوع من الحرية أيضًا
المهم أعتقد إذا كنت لا تقف على
في الوسط وأنت جالس ، سوف يأتي
لعبت دور المبلغين البديل
يلعب في منتصف الميدان ، بدأت المشي منه
أنت ، أنت ، بالنسبة لها ، نوعي يبدأ
عدو لي مهم جدا
بعض الخدمات المعقدة هنا
يمكن أن تأكل حقا
أنت تعمل وأحيانًا تتعب وكل الملاحظات
يجب أن تعمل أيامنا كلها
هذه الحيوانات تتطلب الكثير
انتباه هذا الحب لا يذهب للعمل
في مزاج سيئ ، ربما يكون الطريق ليس كذلك
بودوكر فتنة ماء بينما دافي سونيك
أو تعتز وأنا البومة ورقة راتبي
مؤسسة
فاندامي كورت وهيلدا ينصب
بالتأكيد لديه روح ولي
ضخم لنا دعنا نقول شيئا و
كانت الوحدة فترة كنت فيها قليلا
المخدرات وليس كل التوترات كما لو كان الأمر كذلك
سيأخذون مذكرة الحصان التي أريدها
مواطن حتى نهاية هذا العام
ستسقط قائمة الشطب وسأكون حرفها و
لنذهب إلى
وأي واحد لديه أفضل
على طول حتى يتمكن من التنفس
بشريا
[موسيقى]
تحديد أي الزبدة الأفراد السرطان x
تيمور
المسلمون في فندق أو ايفا مطلي
أومسك انطلق بعيدًا عن هنا أو كان يتذوق العطور
صباح الخير 2 نقيب الكتيبة الخامسة
كورباتوف ، من فضلك ، كيف حال مستنداتك
نختار إيقافه بالمناسبة
سؤال شائع جدا
السائقين لما أحتاجه ، حسنًا ، أولاً
إنها خدعة أحيانًا حتى تصل إلينا
Chuyka يعرف أن يغسل هذا
هذا ليس ضروريا ، الجميع يحلق سوف يغادر جيدا
السائق الأكثر حذرا
سائق لديه بعض
انتهاك سيتم تثبيته للامتثال
الحد الأقصى للسرعة للقيادة في المسرب الأيمن و
ليس بأي حال من الأحوال سوف يعطي ما لديه
هذه المشكلة ليست دائما السائقين في حالة سكر
يأكلون ويهزون على طول الطريق الذي يسافرون به كثيرًا
بعناية شديدة لا تنقل دائما
أي عقاقير غير مشروعة أو
لا اعلم لا قدر الله السلاح متى انتهك
توقف الركوب موجهًا نفسك بدقة
من واقع خبرتي ، فإنه يجلب أحيانًا خاصته
نتيجة ستة أشهر عملت في المكتب
المفتش لكنه بالتأكيد ليس ملكي ، أنا لست كذلك
يمكنني الجلوس ونقل أي أوراق
المهمة هي أنا دائمًا لأنني لا أفعل ذلك
يمكنني الجلوس هناك
لا ، يجب أن يكون هناك دائمًا
بعض الحركة وطلب dps
لما يقرب من 20 عامًا من وضع الخدمة
كان هناك الكثير من الاختلاف
السائقين في حالة سكر غير مناسب المتربة
كان اعتقالي بسيطًا
المشاة هناك يلعب 6 هل يمكنني الركض
يمكن أن يكون الوضع موجودًا وعليك أن تكون كذلك
على استعداد لمعرفة ما يجب القيام به
عمل المنشار في المسافة
السيارة التالية والطريق فارغ
لا يوجد أحد وهي محقة مع صافرة
مرة وإلى اليمين تبعناه جيدًا
أرى أن علامات السائقين
مخمورا ثم يخرج سوف يأخذ
الآن سأقوم بتنسيق وليس السيارة
عملت لا تزال جاهزة سأطفئ السيارة و
ذهبت إلى السيارة لكنني كنت أقف بالقرب من الباب
بالقرب من جانب الراكب ، جلس على مقعد و
الحق دون الجلوس حتى النهاية قيد التشغيل
العتاد الأول وضرب الغاز هنا أنا
قفز على الباب بقدمه اليسرى بنفسه
وصلت ثم الفرامل كانت الأشجار في مكان قريب
والأسوار
إذا لمس الباب المفتوح خلفه
ما نوع الشجرة التي أود مشاركتها
على الصقر
أنت لا تفكر في ذلك ، فأنت تركض إلى النهاية
فلدي القبض عليه بأي ثمن
قف
[تصفيق]
لكن
بالنسبة لي ، الدراجة النارية هي أداة مريحة
الحركة والاحتمال يبدو
افعل ما تحب وأكثر
دعوة ركوب الدراجات النارية
من كلمة ستان خدعة حقوق لنيكولاييف
20 أكتوبر 2015
أنا أعتبر ، كما كان ، يوم تأسيسنا
المجموعات التي التقينا بها لأول مرة
تجمعوا على الدراجات النارية منخفضة و
سائقي السيارات المنخفضة لطالما فكرنا كيف
فوق الاسم
500 كلمة تحفر إعادة توجيهها
كلمة فرنسية لكن البهلواني و
قررت قطع فقط
كان جواز سفرنا صغيرًا في البداية
دراجة نارية تبدو وكأنها طفل
يمكننا ممارسة الحيل
التدريب في المساء وعطلات نهاية الأسبوع
أيام
أي أنه كان مرهقًا جدًا
التدريب أحببنا ذلك
على الرغم من أنه اتضح أن شيئًا كهذا
اتضح أنها رياضة خدمية على أي حال
كل ما تحتاجه هو وقت فراغ من العمل
[موسيقى]
أنا لم أر ، وليس كما في روسيا
أقرب رابطة الدول المستقلة وأنا لا أخشى أن أقول
في عالم مثل هذه المجموعة من رجال الشرطة الذين
اعمل الحيل
أن هناك سيارات ودراجات نارية
إنه عرض شرطي كبير
أي رجال الشرطة النشطين ولكن
الذي يأتي يسأله الكثير من الناس
هل أنتم أول رجال الشرطة
ألستم ممثلين في التمثيل على الإطلاق
الموظفين الذين يخدمون بالفعل
على طرق موسكو ينظرون إليها أكثر من غيرها
إنه لأمر رائع أن ترى عندما يكون هناك الكثير
عندما يصفق هؤلاء الأطفال يبتسمون
في خوف من بعض الحيل
هناك إضافة حادة ، ثم ربما الأكثر
خير ثم بعد ذلك تريد
افعلها مرة اخرى
[موسيقى]
حسنًا ، حيث كان لديهم إبليس في الصلاة
عشاء سوبر دبدوب هو الثاني
التدخين مسموح به
لماذا أحب عملي
للصداقة مع شريك حياتك
كل شيء في الحياة مختلف
لن يخون
أريد أن أكون مرض بلادي يعني
ماذا او ما
يمكنك التأثير على الخارجين عن القانون
توقف عن شيء ويمكن أن يكون الألم أنت
حفظ بعض صوت الحياة
يتجمعون ويتجمعون وينفذون
عمل إرادتنا عملنا دائما هناك
الخير من
ولكن هناك دائما بعض المعارضة
سوف يقاتل حتى لديه المزيد من المال
أعطاني المزيد من المساعدة ولدينا دور
فضائل الشهوة هي بايز
لذلك أنا أتعثر وأسود